whatever you do you only do because God
allows you
love God
[Music]
father Gabriella amort
on the night of June 4th
[Music]
you performed an exorcism
that was not an exorcism
the majority of cases do not require an
exorcism
98 I recommend they buy him to doctors
and psychiatrists
the other two percent
I call it
evil
we have more questions for you father
Mort
you have a problem with me you talk to
my boss
there's a case that needs your attention
bring me the priest
I'm here to help Julia
wrong right
take cautioned their secrets buried
there
it's about the concealed
the church escort against this demon
before
Nevada can cover the top we need to find
out why
you've been played you took the Fate
whatever you do you only do because God
allows it
did you allow that
imagine what could happen if the devil
possessed the soul of the Pope's
Exorcist who will defend
my faith
does not require defense
foreign